hello youtubers i'm here at the World
Economic Forum and I have one piece of
advice and that is exercise but exercise
three things first of all if you're
lucky enough to live somewhere in the
world where you can vote exercise your
right to vote because that's one of the
most important things you can do to
improve our global citizenship second
thing is exercised kindness certainly on
a day to day basis there's something
that each of us can do to exhibit
kindness whether it's locally or
globally and lastly just exercise all of
us at CDC know that that is the most
important thing you can do to protect
your health so have fun and exercise
thank you